good morning everybody and apologies for
the late start of the meeting today
various issues that hopefully will
internet will keep with us and all sorts
of other things so welcome everybody
my name's kathy guthrie and i'm the
chairman today
so
please ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons whilst
in the chamber and in the communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face
covering at all times unless you're
sitting down or if you are exempt from
doing so
and that you use the hand sanitizer and
wipes provided
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt at the
meeting you will be uh you may be asked
to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
we will be using the e-voting for this
meeting on the modern.gov app so members
can you make sure you're logged in and
ready to vote
fire safety arrangements if you hear the
alarm leave the building immediately via
a fire exit make your way to the
assembly point which is the ipswich town
football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exits at each end of the floor do
not enter the atrium ground floor area
walkways
if you are in the atrium at the time of
the alarm follow the signs to the
nearest fire exit
use the stairs and not the lifts and we
do have a problem with the stairs so
members will direct to the back stairs
if we do have to evacuate
do not re-enter the building until
you're told it is safe to do so
the council members of the public and
press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
so the introductions today the area
planning manager is gemma walker morning
gemma
our legal advisor christine flitner
thank you very much good morning
christine
case officers mark russell
morning and alex breadman
and vincent
vincent
he'll come and join us later because
he's got other things on his mind there
governance officer alicia norman welcome
to you
um and um we um also have mandy who's
driving our internet today
so i think that's everybody and then the
good people of you who are sitting at
the back there you've got three minutes
to speak when you're invited to do so
and there are other members of the
public at the back there too
so
we also have ward members
of councillor mellon who's on the
committee but we all know what happens
when you become a ward member
as you choose i think we're quite happy
for you to stay where you are
so
apologies for absence and substitutions
do we have any apologies
thank you chair we have apologies from
councillor norris and councillor gould
uh substituting today we have councillor
matthison and councillor bern
thank you
declarations of pecuniary and
non-interest
by members non-pecuniary interests by
members
are there any to declare
none to declare
declarations of lobbying
none
declarations of sight personal site
visits
now then you've got to cast your minds
back confirmation of the minutes of the
me
councillor stringer i do beg your pardon
sorry i wanted to declare yourself i
want to declare an interest in item c
uh my house is 60 meters to the north of
the site
thank you councillor
update i won't be voting on that item
but i will take place in the debate
thank you absolutely thank you very much
indeed no vote thank you
councillor stringer thank you very much
right where are we um
so yes we've got to cast our minds back
to the minutes on the 24th of november
i'm sure you've all read them and had a
look at them are there any points of
accuracy please
no
so can i have a proposal
counselor cast and followed by
counsellor
um oh dave i've forgotten your name
muller sorry i'll tell you it's not a
good day
so on that basis may we go to the vote
please
thank you chair members the vote is now
open
um
lastly
i am happy to agree those it's just i
haven't got the
item up
thank you thank you chair so that means
that six votes four and two abstentions
so that's carried
receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
done received chair
thank you
um so the schedule of applications uh to
be heard today will go in the order that
they sit on the papers
and so i'll now invite the case officer
mark russell to introduce the first case
please that's dc2004444444444444
thank you
thank you chair good morning members
ladies and gentlemen i shall begin the
presentation now with luck
some of the members here may recall that
this application was before the
referrals committee back in 2019
uh when it received listed building
consent it was tied to a planning
application
for the development of the former
mid-suffolk hq site in needham market
the first slide you see
shows you the two parcels of land
and there's a larger blowout so you can
see where it is in relation to the built
form of needham market
we're concentrating on
the parcel which is labeled zone
two
and that contains the old hq and the
range of buildings which were joined to
it
particularly we're really looking at
what's shaded in red there which is the
listed building itself so that's a
historic hersley house which is the
northernmost of the buildings and then
the later edition just to the south of
it
much of what you're about to look at
has already got consent
the
workforce is on-site constructing new
dwellings
this relates to the listed building
itself and really we're just looking at
fairly minor tweaks
to the scheme which was approved back in
2019.
just to remind you of the constraints of
the site is shaded in the usual color
the conservation area is over to the
east and there are many listed buildings
on the attractive high street of needham
market
i'm going to show you these two slides
and skip through the next few because
i've got some better versions of them
but these are the ones that you were
given in your in your bundle
so
that's the existing elevations
and to note on the proposed
to the left of the main hersley house
building is the roof terrace
or roof flat should i say and then to
the right is a new two-story extension
so if i take you through these which are
on your pack don't help with this
presentation
right so this was the
scheme that got consent in 2019 i'm
going to show you the 2019 2022 and then
what the changes are so 2019 was this
2022 is this a slightly different
notation but if i just take you to this
basically um
you can see that the red shows what what
fabric is table to be removed and that's
largely
modern partition walls and mostly in the
modern more well the more recent
addition to hersley house
so
the notable changes at ground floor
level are if you see over on the left
that the pink
thick wall there that's actually not
just the wall it's showing how much
bigger the extensions table to be so
it's about
a meter or so a couple of meters wider
and longer it's the same extension that
you just saw but it's just a little bit
bigger
and there's some other small changes
inside as well so i've numbered them for
you that they're very cosmetic um
they're just changing positions of doors
um you can see with points two and three
there that was to be a through door
that's now to be a door to a cupboard
for example so the minor changes like
that
and looking at further changes you can
see that the bathroom is to be made
larger than it was going to be so the
walls are slightly pushed back and that
also helps to better expose historic
features like the cornice and the old
coving which the historic buildings
officer was keen to try and preserve the
appearance of
and there's changes to circulation space
if you can see between 2019 and 2022
there's some minor changes there
so going to the first floor
a little bit of fabric removal there the
same as with uh the ground floor but not
a huge amount there just you can see
there's small
small room small partitions
the first raw changes replicate those at
the ground floor obviously with the
extension to the left
and then i've circled
several
other minor changes and these really
relate to configuration or
reconfiguration of
of the usable rooms um you can see the
kitchen's been reconfigured uh three
bedrooms have been brought down to two
bedrooms and reworking the circulation
space
and so on
the second floor
again this fabric move are just really
minor points basically
so again on the second floor you have
minor elements which are being changed
like this so
repositioning of kitchenette the
ensuites reposition new corridor
bathroom kitchenette and other bathrooms
are all reconfigured and repositioned
just to make the space work better
this has
almost no effect on the historic fabric
relating to the previous
consent
finally
we're up in the roof now you can see
those skylights
those are tabled not to be there now
see fabric removal is virtually none
um and that is now to be basically as a
void space to better respect the layout
of the old building
so to remind ourselves of the building
we're talking about
here is hersley house
and that is an artist's impression of
what the extended section would look
like and this is from the old
application but it's exactly the same
nothing's changed
and again just to remind ourselves what
we're talking about these the buildings
we should be removed
and the features that i mentioned such
as these are the ones which are now
going to have their um
full glory better exposed for enjoyment
of people using the building
and the other issue that's come up is
the doors these are to be kept in situ
but blocked in such a way as
to be um fire and sound resistant but to
be able to be recovered for use at some
later date if necessary
and that members is it it's um a series
of small changes uh which basically
revisit the list of building consent
which was granted in 2019.
thank you very much indeed do members
have any questions for mark
council of war boys
thank you
um curious really there's no discussion
in the documents from
our heritage
officers
concerning the harm to
a potential harm to a listed building
i've looked through and there's
something from place services but the
only comments i can find are from
uh
historic england
but nothing from our own heritage people
yeah the i mean the issues that arose
were um i think that the key issue that
came up was the uh the issue of doors et
cetera did come up and
also the roof terrace come up again but
that sort of already got consent
um the discussions were had with the
place services um
historic buildings officers on site and
also the with the applicant um and we
had a meeting there it was about a month
ago actually and he's he's now is happy
with what's been proposed and has has
said so in his response
which hopefully is in your table of
papers
could you just direct us to that if it's
in the table papers please
hang on a minute counsellor just one
moment can come can we find them can um
gemma find them in our table papers i
mean it's a very good point counsellor
um but if
we can accept what's been said but it
should be in our table papers a very
good point so we'll find out that i've
got the summary on page 28 but perhaps
mark is it the full version in the
sorry did i say table pencil bundle in
the bundle you should have the historic
building office's response which page
where's the bundle um
i don't know what document i'm
i think that was the point that cancer
was making that we have a comment from
um historic england and we have a
comment from place services isn't it
cancer is that place services is is the
um
is the consultant for this because it's
our application
sorry if that wasn't clear
initially our own um
heritage officer had commented but that
was that was admin mistake they
shouldn't have done because it's out so
so place services is for this purpose
our historic building officer sorry
because this place services only
relates to the internal alterations
i might assume that
with regard to the um
removal of the mansard roof and
the um
roof terrace that's not part of this
application
it is technically part of this
application but it's already got consent
so if members were to deny these
internal changes the applicant could
just do them anyway
um it was looked at last time and
it was weighed up against a public
benefit and we found in its favor so
that has consent and it has planning
permission
so so really we asked our historic
buildings officer
place services to
talk to the applicant about the internal
configurations and the treatment of the
internal fabric
that that's the crux of today's
application
really thank you that's
yeah sorry if that wasn't clear yeah
thank you for that counselor stringer
yep uh thank you
in the past i have had the pleasure of
going through some of those doors that
are mentioned in the application and
they are very very fine quality doors i
was a little unclear about
what's going to happen to them
and is there any chance we can get a bit
of clarity in what's actually going to
happen to the doors
we have the applicant here who can or
the agent rather who can give some more
information in a moment um but but the
the fundamentals of it are that the
doors will be looked after in place but
will be covered over to make them
compliant with building regulations
so it'd be a hidden away door but um
visible from one side not from the other
thank you for that any further questions
thank you no
um
well
we have the agent who is here mr anthony
polanski
and he is present today but he doesn't
wish to make a representation but may
answer any questions so do members have
any questions at all
no i think we've sort of cleared it with
what we heard counsellor stringer yes
just about the doors i take it they'll
be visible from
the public access or the private
building
yes that's correct so on the on the
lobby side and the idea is that because
they're separating residential rooms we
need to improve the acoustic separation
so they'll be insulated on the flat side
thank you very much any further
questions
thank you very much indeed so
thank you chair
whilst i accept the principle of a
residential conversion i support needham
market town council's comments on page
26 of the papers particularly with
regard to the proposed reef extension to
the more modern southern extension which
i believe will be out of keeping with
the existing street scene and the
adjacent list of buildings in a conv in
a conservation area the ancient monument
society expresses much of the same
reservations within their council t
response on page 27
however i note that the planning officer
states that this is not proposed to be
changed with this current application
which is unfortunate regards counselor
mike norris
thank you very much
and if anybody wants to comment in that
we'll do during the debate
so thank you very much
and in fact we now open up the matter
for debate who would like to start
councillor matheson thank you
yeah just um
just a procedural point really i i think
with the other um
applications on this this wider site i
have just um noted the fact that i do
live in need of market i do not
represent need a market on the council
and i cannot see the site from my home
okay
that's very helpful thank you councillor
um one thing that uh councillor stringer
mentioned and i must admit i had a smile
to my face when i saw the doors at
needham market and remember whizzing
through them on many an occasion
and so i'm pleased that a lot of it's
going to be preserved under that basis i
just do have a an interesting comment um
well i think it is um the void space and
i do apologize to everyone i'm out of
order the void space will it be used for
anything at all
my understanding is not um but if you
want to
speak to the agent about that asking
that question i think it's just i think
it's just in terms of being more
sympathetic to the building i don't
think it'd be used for anything
can i just ask you is it going to be
used for anything at all
so when you say the void space
specifically
that was the on the roof space wasn't it
where the um i think i had it on as big
can we sorry can we show the slide again
where the skylights would have been on
that flank
um yeah what we've done is we've opened
i think originally there was going to be
a flat a level roof on there so we've
opened it up so it's effectively a
double height living room space so we
just so the space will remain as it was
and so that's what we've done
well as you go up you've got bedrooms on
either side on the upper level but the
it's open to the living room
yeah um
more than happy with this particular
application and the recommendations made
in the the conditions on page
28 sorry 32
and i would actually move
approval on this one chair
thank you thank you very much indeed and
councillor carsten looking for a second
here thank you
very much madam chairman yeah i think
this is a sympathetic plan i think it um
it's a it's an improvement in the layout
in there
um more useful um
apartments um
yeah i've i've no issues with this i
think this has been
been done very well so i'd like to um
second councillor muller
please thank you very much does anyone
wish to speak to the
recommendation there anybody else wish
to speak at all enter the debate
well in that case then um i thank very
much everybody's input and would you
like to go to the vote for us please
thank you chair members of vote is now
open
thank you chair that is seven votes four
and one abstentions that is carried
thank you very much and in view of the
late start if we can keep going on to
the next item please thank you very much
indeed mark
so we move on
okay
alex thank you very much when you're
ready if you'd like to present the case
that would be lovely thank you
thank you chair
good afternoon members um i have
dc2200357 today to present this is a
householder application for the erection
of a single story front and rear
extension
um just for clarity this application is
well the applicant is a colleague at the
council
hence the need to present this to you
so here we have the red line plan i've
just presented this before the aerial
viewings just to make the next slides a
little bit
easier to read basically but the
applicant has has provided the blue line
around the the residential cartilage
with the red line around
essentially where the er the proposal is
going to extend
again we can see the aerial map
an existing residential area
and again
in terms of constraints on site
we essentially don't have any there
there are no major constraints on site
and the site is within the um
the settlement boundary for star upland
here we have the existing elevations um
draw your attention mostly to this
existing side extension and the front
porch
as you see when we move to the proposed
plans we're essentially just extending
forwards beyond this
at the front of the house we're going to
be wrapping around and creating a new
porch it only extends about 0.6 meters
forward of the existing porch
we're going to have a slight raising of
the roof and again extending around to
the rear there's no there's no wrap
around at the rear of the house though
and again
just the floor plans you can see the
wrap around at the front
and again
modest extensions on either side really
just some site photos now
see the existing house and the neighbor
we do have this small um
wall that extends a little bit further
along to the boundary that's going to
stay in place with the gate so there's
still rear access to the rear of the
house sorry
and then just another just from another
angle just so we can see
essentially the driveway so we can see
that that's not going to be uh affected
too much as a result of the proposal and
we're still going to have enough room
for for another vehicle on the site
um and and that is it um the officer
recommendation is for approval and uh
yeah thank you very much
thank you very much indeed any questions
for the officer
no
um and um
we
don't have anyone other than a statement
from
councillor
ebon i've got one here i think unless
you haven't got it
you've got them both now okay i was
picking it up two statements one from
both ward members uh rachel's if you'd
like to read it out thank you
thank you chairs this is a ward members
statement from councillor eben
she says application dc-2200357
is supported by the parish council and
while it is a set of single-story
extensions somewhat different to
neighbouring properties as it is only at
committee due to being the relation of a
council employee i have no additional
comments to make kind regards counsellor
even
would you like me to do a council of
welling statement as well
so this statement is from councillor
wellum who is also a board member
he says my only comment on the detail is
to ask committee to note that the
extension into the front garden will be
in front of the building line and to
consider whether or not that this is
appropriate regards
thank you very much indeed so we need to
open the matter up for debate because we
haven't got anyone else
um
to speak so who would like to speak
first
councillor bern i saw and then
councillor matheson thank you sorry yes
i wasn't i was just going to ask the um
officer if she'd kindly repeat the last
sentence of uh councillor mellon's um
submission
of course yeah
i think it's councillor williams
we've got so many model names so his
ward member statement is essentially
only just one sentence so i'll read it
out completely again he says my only
comment on the detail is to ask
committee to note that the extension
into the front garden will be in front
of the building line and to consider
whether or not this is appropriate
thank you councillor matheson
now into debate so councillor thank you
yeah i i was going to
ask um if planning officers
were were concerned or happy regarding
the point that council weather makes
about the building line
um
yeah
personally
like i said um
there is an existing porch we are
we're only extending
0.6 beyond that as it is i don't think
it's a significant increase in beyond
the beyond the front building line
like i said i think the extension
overall is is fairly modest
can you just clarify the distance for
permitted development rights
or the size for when you have to when
you have a pd
so you can't come beyond the front
elevation under permitted development so
that wouldn't be allowed and in terms of
off the side you're looking at half the
width of the original dwelling so
potentially as a side extension it might
be permitted i don't know if it's got
its rights intact or not but in in
theory that would be a possibility so
the projection itself beyond the front
we wouldn't usually be able to consider
under permitted development
that's interesting okay
please
yeah i i don't have any issue with this
at all um i think this is a this is an
improvement on a house it's um
it looks good a dining room a downstairs
shower room is always a good addition to
a house
it's sensible and it's um
it it's nothing um it's it's there's
nothing outrageous about it so um i'd
like to um propose that we
grant planning permission with
conditions on this please thank you
um councillor muller
uh thank you yes i'm more than happy to
second uh councillor casten's um
recommendation to grant planning
permission with the conditions as stated
in the papers thank you
thank you very much and councillor
matheson
ah sorry
councillor bern please
thank you chair um yes i agree with uh
would agree with the proposer and and
second
i think this um
is an improvement of the front elevation
uh
its appearance and i think it adds to
the interest of the street scene so
notwithstanding
i mean yes there are benefits internally
as well but i think that's an important
benefit externally too thank you
thank you councillor anyone else wishing
to speak
no well i have a proposal and a seconder
so may we go to the vote please thank
you
thank you chair members the vote is now
open on your modern.gov
thank you chair that is eight votes for
so that is unanimous
watch everybody and if we can just have
a very quick ten minute break before the
next item if that would be satisfactory
to everyone thank you very much indeed
well thank you very much indeed and
we're now back to
the next and last item on the agenda
land on the west side broad road backton
suffolk dc 2104
779
and we'll ask vincent pierce the case
officer to present the case if you would
thank you very much
thank you chair good morning members
ladies and gentlemen and
guests
this is a reserved matters application
for 65 dwellings
based on an outline planning application
that was granted at the end of 2020.
as we say in acton
just to remind members
the outline planning permission is
accompanied by a section 106
agreement that delivers 35 affordable
housing open space and play
primary school contributions
and secondary school transport
contributions
clearly that's not a matter for you
today but i thought it it helps to
remind ourselves of what went before and
what mitigation there is for the
community
i also want to go into a little bit of
detail about condition 12 that was
attached to the outline
planning permission because included in
the in the
permission
is a requirement to
implement
highway improvements from the site
southwards along broad road into
plow hill and under the railway bridge
that includes the provision for the
first time ever of a footpath where
there isn't one at the moment and there
have been some concerns expressed about
the nature of those works
but the principle of those works has
been agreed
and to secure their delivery we we've
used a mechanism that members may
recall that we used in stowe upland and
we call it our triple lock system it's a
grampian condition
so that the
engineering drawings of of those works
have to be agreed with ourselves and the
local highway authority prior to any
work starting on site and my colleagues
at suffolk county council are dealing
with the section 278
order
as we speak
that condition also requires
all the approved detail to be
implemented
in accordance with the timetable to be
agreed
and last of all there can be no
occupation of any of the dwellings
on this development site until
those improvement works have been
implemented
so what i'm
saying to members this morning is that
is not a matter before you
we are purely looking at the reserved
matters and as always my presentation is
merely here to illustrate and supplement
the report that you've all
received
unusually i don't usually describe a
developer to you because
that isn't a material consideration but
i think it's worth just pointing out
that keep moat homes
are not particularly familiar to us in
this part of
the world but they are in the top 10
in the uk for the delivery of
numbers of houses so they are a big
company they have an ethical
um
standpoint and way of
operating
we have previously approved a heap
scheme in old newton
not a million miles away from from this
site
just to familiarize ourselves backton to
the north of stone market
and to the east of elmswell
approached by the b-triple 1-3
more localized context bacton itself is
surrounded by
a range of villages and hamlets the
flashing dot is the application site and
you'll see that it sits to the east of
the railway line
here's the application site
you'll notice that the majority of what
we might call built
up back to there is highlighted in the
dusky orange color
recently committees your sister
committee and yourselves have looked at
an application
in this point and that's been approved
for 85 dwellings
on this one people cross the railway to
get to the sports facilities on the
other side of the railway
we have another 51
homes
in this position
very few constraints on this site there
is a public footpath to the south but it
doesn't adjoin this particular site so
it is unconstrained
just to
again familiarize yourself on the left
is the outline planning permission
and on the right is the current layout
that we're discussing this morning and
on the slide on the left in the black
dashed line i've shown where the edge of
development is
and also on that slide i've shown where
the existing ditches that runs across
the site in blue
you'll notice that the outline
illustrative layout didn't necessarily
relate particularly well to the
existing ditch
what we've
done in discussion with
keep moat is to
pull the houses further away from the
railway which i think is is good for
amenity
reasons but we've also been able to
increase the amount of open space within
the development so the area in green is
where we've
we've clawed back additional
open space
here's the site again and we'll just
quickly superimpose
the layout the green arrow is the access
point broadly midway on the frontage
taken directly off broad road
some shots of the site so we're looking
southward
open field
trees all around the edge
no hedgerow in this position
you can start to see hedgerow as we look
further north again the trees in the
distance on the edge of the site
and to the north side an established
hedge
the additional open spaces help to
soften the edge of this development as
i've shown there obviously we have
gardens all of a reasonable size
but also superimposed into this
new landscape are a series of suds
features
which includes actually suds alongside
the the highway that's something that
you have been asking us to try and
secure and we've been pushing developers
for a long time to actually embrace the
idea of building in swales into the
development
and
fortunately keep motive accepted that
challenged and run with it and were very
pleased with the their approach to suds
access to the site principally you come
in where the blue arrow is
the main estate accesses the blue the
flashing
turquoise color is the raised table and
then there are a series of
residential streets that run off of it
a good
mix of forms across the site so we have
examples of terraces semi-detached units
detached units
and through a series of amendments we
have secured
bungalows in this position the outline
application permission required two
bungalows we have the two bungalows it
also required two masonettes
one masonette bean
two flats
that's in this position
so the
range of
forms is is good something
keep motive worked with us to achieve
we do have the 22 affordable units and
they are now following a series of
amendments in the
in the sizes that were required by our
strategic housing team as
specified in the section 106 agreement
so we have a
cluster in this position
the majority are affordable rented
i think in the proportion of 70 30 which
is again what our strategic housing
colleagues required and then we have
another cluster
at this point
good elevations good detailing so we
have examples of exposed rafter feet
decorative banding
flat brick arches
door hoods
bay windows and the example on the right
is a corner turning unit and i know that
members are keen to ensure that where we
have buildings that sit on the corner we
don't have flank end walls
that we actually have visual interest
that also allows surveillance out of any
adjoining open space so we have secured
that and again keep motive cooperated
with us
an example here where we see
there's a single toilet window there we
could with a bit of adjustment and i
haven't discussed this with keep mode
simply turn that into two and the
proportions of that gable are i would
argue enhanced but that's something we
can deal with under the recommendation
were you minded to agree the
recommendation and grant and approve
reserved
matters next slide again
you'll notice on the far right another
interesting
side wall that looks out over open
space again it's not a blank brick wall
but there's a lot of visual interest and
good surveillance out
this is the masonette unit and you're
so on the ground floor in this position
sorry
here
you come in at the front that occupies
most of the ground floor for the flat
above you come in at the side
and simply
work your way up the stairs and then
you're in the flat above to all intent
and purpose you wouldn't know that that
was
technically flat it looks like a house
but there are two good sized
affordable units rented units inside
in terms of the
layout each has access to its own garden
so the first floor has windows that look
out onto its own garden so you're not
having the neighbor looking into your
garden and the ground floor again their
own garden
with a direct access straight out into
their own garden
so there's adequate room for
children to play
outdoor drying
the use of masonettes i think is a very
good way of delivering one bed units in
a way that gives everyone good amenity
space
simple bungalows
again interesting
street scenes i'll just quickly take you
through a series of those
on this one the grade buildings are set
back in the distance so
between the grey building and ourselves
is the back garden but what we've got
are brick walls and all the principal
prominent frontages so there are no
close boarded fences and then there are
trees
this is an important part of the broad
road frontage so
you'll notice when we get to landscaping
there will be a new hedgerow planted
here and here and between those you come
out on a new path
so again soft edges to that development
and the development is set back from the
road
just some more examples of those street
views
in terms of residential immunity the
nearest neighbor sits here
the green triangle which is this house
here
these are bungalows immediately adjacent
and there is a 17 meter
gap
there will be no issue of overlooking
one because it's a bungalow and two
because of the distance of the immediate
neighbor
and again
through discussion the bungalows were
cited here in order to deliver
that safeguard to the amenity of
neighbours
this shows where we've got the
1.8 meter high brick walls in all the
key visual
points in order to enhance and secure
good townscape
we've tracked all the
refuse collection arrangements
our waste
service
is very satisfied with the arrangements
being made by keep moat
parking
again
on this site we have no examples of
triplex parking so i'm sure members will
be pleased to see that we have at last a
scheme where there is no triplex parking
arrangements each
property has access to its own spaces so
for example at the top
there are two spaces in front of that
unit in green
that's how they work
on the corner they have direct access to
their parking spaces
some of the houses have them adjacent to
the house on a
private driveway and then the yellow
dots are visitor parking
there is very good
level of visitor parking across the site
not on the street but in in specific
spaces that will not be conveyed with
the properties
and the same happens on the southern end
of the site
and you can see the arrangements good
visitor parking again and there's
actually
some parking spaces around the place
space
although we would expect residents here
to be walking to the
facility
extensive suds network with a basin
in this corner and this also helps to
separate the houses from the
the railway which
goes
south west north east in on the edge
we are
comfortable now that all the relevant
drainage authorities are satisfied with
the
drainage details we've had confirmation
from them now
what we were also looking at is when it
comes to the detailed landscaping which
we are conditioning we will ensure that
there are the right species for wetland
habitats as well as creating a broad and
diverse new
habitats across the site
and you'll notice because of
the ditch
and other connections we're actually
creating a
or reinforcing the natural
wildlife corridors
through the site and then along the
railway and up into the
the countryside
in terms of the basin
it will be dry most of the year but
enough capacity in there for a one in
two year flood event
one in 30
year flood event and then a 100 year
plus 40 climate change
event so our drainage colleagues at
suffolk county are very pleased with the
um the details and as i say we will
ensure that the species planted within
and around are suitable for a
wetland
habitat
but members will recall what we won't be
advocating is the use of bull rushes
because of their invasive
nature
and again there's a smaller basin just
to the south
in terms of landscaping we are
pleased with the strategic
landscaping in terms of
those parts of the site that are due to
be landscaped but we are requiring
further detail in terms of the species
through condition
so you'll probably have wild flower
meadows
set amongst the trees in these positions
reinforcing existing planting and we'll
have a new
planting belt behind
the basin so between the basin the
houses and the railway there will be a
new
planting strip
good surveillance of all of those spaces
from frontages or the sides of
properties with
bay windows and
other windows at first floor so again
we're very pleased with
security and safety on the northern edge
that is a dense existing
belt of trees and hedgerow houses on
that point we'll back onto
onto that
just to reinforce what's happening on
the road frontage we have the vision
this is the southern end so we have
vision splay which will remove a little
bit of the existing hedgerow there is an
existing ditch that will be retained and
form part of the sud system
there is a new footpath sorry that's the
a new hedgerow that's going to be
planted and then we have the new
footpath and you'll notice that
in
on the map this is north this is south
so you'd be able to come from this
estate use this new path
and come out onto a new section of
footwear that will take you right the
way around and under the railway bridge
so we are knitting this development into
the rest of backton which the most of
most of bacton is to the west of the
railway bridge but we are ensuring that
we knit this community in the rest of
the community
in baghdad
as part of the internal
footpath system
that's a very quick shot just showing
you that under the
outline planning position we'll get a
section of new footwear
the existing small section of footwear
here will be widened the existing
footpath here grey is retained and then
we have the improvements under the under
the bridge
this i think is this scheme is achieving
new levels of sustainability in terms of
what members ask us as officers to
secure this goes way beyond your
policies
and i think it's important to note that
we have 100
ndss achieved on the site
100 of the units will
achieve part m2 of the building
sorry apart m42 of the building rigs
and we will see 100 air source heat
pumps on the site
we also see the new footwear coming
through
as part of this development which
assists connectivity we will get
ecological mitigation i've started to
explain how we will increase
biodiversity on the site
and we will get full electric vehicle
charging so were you minded to approve
these details i think this would set a
new benchmark against which we would
judge other developers in how far are
they going
to respond to the climate emergency and
start to think about the post gas boiler
era
so our recommendation to you is set out
in the report we are
recommending
approving all of the
conditions that have been
asked of us
we're asking that you give the chief
planning officer the authority to issue
those we'll just tidy up the responses
we've received but we're now confident
that all our counselees are in favor
of approving the conditions
and then to grant reserved matters
approval thank you chair
thank you very much vince that was a
very clear presentation lots of
information imparted to us there
um
so
members do you have questions counselor
cast and then councillor matheson
then councillor stringer and then um
the council will go with the committee
to start with did council of war boys
have you
vague hand up
okay and then i'll come to councillor
mellon okay and that order then please
counselor cast thank you very much um i
haven't quite got to grips with the
frontage of this um you said that
there's the new hedge going in down
beside broad road is there a um is there
a hedge being planted on the
north end of broad road and the south
end but there's a
bit in the middle that's got no hedge
could you just clear that up please
engaged
thank you council kessler i didn't
necessarily explain that very well what
i should have said is that the existing
hedgerow north of the access road
will be retained
so i was it i was largely focusing on
the frontage south of the access road
because that is where the new hedgerow
will will be planted now let's see if we
can
here we are so
north this is existing hedgerow that is
not affected by the vision display
so it's in this section where some of
the planting that's already there
has to be taken out to achieve the
vision display and this is the section
of
sorry this is yeah
all of this is
new hedgerow
does that
yes thank you that that's great
thank you for that councillor matheson
yeah i fear that that's just confused me
more actually um
i thought half of the frontage
was without hedge at the moment
and and i thought i also saw
one of the plans showing how much the
hedging that were being removed
is that that's all from we got the plan
of that one that shows the removal
um and um
yeah i thought there was one that
actually showed what was what was
removed but my question really is is
should we not be putting the access
point such in the air in this stretch
that hasn't got any hedge so that we
don't have to remove any hedge
really that that's question one
um i have others
want to do them one at a time
if we quickly go back so that we can see
the
oh
no
just gonna go so we can see the whole of
the site
well there we are
so
here we have existing hedge that is
retained
you're right this section
appeared not to have any hedge but i
suspect there are still some remnants of
hedge in there but when that photograph
was taken
this was open
so it's this section south of the access
to this corner that would have the new
hedgerow well let's say you could
actually say
a hedgerow where there doesn't appear to
be one might be the best way to describe
it
but i'd hear what you say why can't the
axis go in here but this is
virtually midway
in order to achieve
good vision in both directions the ideal
location on the straight road for an
access is broadly in the middle
so we've actually there is minimal
damage to any existing floor
even by having an access in this
position and what we're doing is
actually enhancing
flora along the frontage but the good
news is that the the established hedge
that you saw
i didn't explain this very well is
actually being retained
yeah yeah i mean that
showing the removal of a hedge isn't
there anywhere i think i'm happy enough
with that
um yeah the
i wanted to have another look at the um
the 1.8 meter walls um they're quite big
things um
i wonder what whether we that was i
think a slide 25 or 24.
um
that helps us
let's quickly shoot through if we can
yes
so
here we have a wall between
connecting two side gardens
again connecting between two side
gardens
this is the curved wall around the
corner these are all in what you might
say are prominent visual
positions
1.8 meter
it's not as tall as me it is a standard
height for a boundary
it isn't the low
wall but then you wouldn't expect a low
brick wall
to enclose effectively private gardens
so each of these is a private garden
behind so it gives the
privacy but in terms of townscape
that is much i would argue is a much
nicer detail than a close boarded fence
which often starts to deteriorate far
quicker than the brick wall the benefit
of the brick wall of course is it should
last for a much longer time and stay in
good condition
whereas you start to see people painting
their fences different colour of
staining them different colours and it
all starts to look a bit
hot potch so from an urban design point
of view you would want to see brick
enclosing walls in prominent
locations something we we try and
achieve across all new developments yeah
yes thank you i mean i i i say it was it
was a bit quick and i wanted to have a
look i think the only the only question
that i've got now i see it
carefully um is
if the
the ones facing broad road
um those sides to brawl don't i mean
we've we've got a hedge and a ditch
there as well
i mean i can i can entirely see the
point of the the you know the urban
design etc
where
those sides are facing to the roads
which all the others are um i just
wondered you know whether whether really
walls are a bit excessive there and it
would be
nicer to
actually just just develop the hedge a
bit thicker or something
can i just ask john that you bring that
up when we have a bit of a debate
very useful points
um now then council
[Music]
stringer i think was next weren't you
thank you thank you chair just for a bit
of clarity uh on the hedge uh i know
that the existing hedge goes from the
watercourse
north the entire length of the site so
according to the planning
shoot 50 of the existing hedge will be
removed
just for clarity
you can look at it on street view it's
there the picture was taken in july 2021
uh
just want to clarify a few points this
isn't this won't be the first time ever
there was a footpath connecting the
village to this park part
the two parts of the village
there was one that went over the railway
up until 1962 and it's still there there
is a ramp that goes either side of the
bridge but it's been cut off by network
rally in 1962.
uh
just also
you said the the
you point to dwellings that were the
nearest to existing dwellings
there are
some other dwellings proposed on this
site that are nearer
to approved dwellings
there are some approved dwellings in the
back garden of mizpah
and they will be directly looking window
to window
on the proposed
development you just wanted to ask you
you suggested that the new path will
assist council stringer can i just stop
you there that point that you've made
there i wonder if it might help us all
to understand it and not forget
could you put up the
the plan which just demonstrates what
councillor stringer is is advising us of
it would certainly help my understanding
sorry to interrupt the flow but
that plant oh sorry that plan helps so
does that one uh if you see where the
green arrow is yeah right where that red
pointer just was yeah keep going left
with there there are two new dwellings
approved right
there face
north
so they're facing the row of dwellings
that are on the proposed site
so so when you said the nearest
dwelling that will be overlooked
that's actually not strictly true and do
we know the distance between the
dwellings and their back garden to the
back garden of these and the other
dwellings yeah
they're about they're about three and a
half to four meters away the width of an
access
you mean the gardens or the all the
properties properties
so they don't have a garden at that not
at the front no
they have a garden at the rear of them
right
the access goes there's a road in
between isn't it there is there's
another there's a road
so it's just the width of the access
driveway but but there is a road in
between got it
okay
yeah
but there's still there's still a road
in between is what i'm trying to
establish no
i'm confused
okay uh and the the third third point uh
you mentioned that the new pathway will
assist connectivity
uh
can
is that also for cyclists
the path is two meters
not three meters so it wouldn't be the
shared footwear cycleway
sorry did you say it would or it
wouldn't
wouldn't
counsellor war boys did you have a
question now you've heard what you've
heard
i can't i can't put a couple in yes i've
been thinking
um the first one it relates to the
previous slide in
council stringers um comments uh the 17
meter gardens
uh will the development rights in those
gardens be
prescribed or
in order to maintain those as um
buffers
is that something we could consider when
we go into debate um vince we can and if
we haven't removed an outline i would
say that is a very good
suggestion
we'll come into debate on that but the
question is at the moment
no at the moment yeah the second
question is the with regards to the i do
find it's it's good that there's so many
swales and attenuation basins and
ditches and whatever um
what um
provision has been made for the ongoing
maintenance of these
that is something we can certainly ask
our guests from keep mode to respond to
because a lot of it will be under
management company
okay thank you
and that's very interesting that's a
point i got ready to to ask but you've
done that for us thank you very much
indeed
so one more question from our committee
member and then i'll come to council oh
oh another oh we've got others go on
councillor councillor carsten thank you
very much
um
we've got some houses quite near to a
raised up
rail track
there have we looked into
the noise levels
for those houses near us to the um
the railway
we have and uh our environmental health
colleagues who deal with knives are
satisfied that suitable attenuation can
be achieved
again
yeah thank you yeah um it's a little bit
tricky doing it electronically um the
on page
107 i i think we we've promised a verbal
update on the
contentious um
or well it was contentious issue of the
mix of the affordables
um and there's apparently
references page 138
in my note there
[Applause]
which is indeed the
comments from the housing enabling
officer
they were unhappy
um
so are they are they now sufficiently
happy because we're not getting what
they originally asked for clearly
i'm grateful i'm grateful to you council
matheson i should have of course said
on the table papers we have got their
updated
comments so apologies for not um
pointing it out at the front they are
very happy now that the mix as amended
through discussion now
is exactly is what they required in the
first place
it is so apologies i should have said at
the start to be fair to you councillor
councillor mellon i think we can let you
loose with your questions
uh thank you chair um
castle string has already asked one of
them
but i have a few others um
so first one um the section 106 uh
agreement doesn't mention a sum for the
footway works is there
uh some set aside for that and is that
limited uh
in amounts
and another question on the footway is
um
part of the footweight the existing
footwear you said is to be retained
but i'm aware that that footway is not
two meters wide at that point because
it's between
the highway and people's front gardens
as it's probably
a meat or maybe a little bit more is
that proposed to be improved or widened
somehow i've got a few other questions
should we start with those
the cramping condition doesn't fix a sum
so under the section 278 agreement it'll
cost
what it'll cost in order to
get approved by suffolk county council
the section of retained footway cannot
be widened
so it will remain as it is that was the
grey section on that plan
okay thank you um the question on the
pumping station um
i'm a little bit concerned about the
sighting of that because it's very near
one of the approved dwellings
um
from the the the back garden of mizpah
which is
that long strip along the south of the
development and it's also very close to
the dwelling to the west which is called
mallards
which is accessed from pound hill
i just wonder whether that
could have been
cited somewhere else or or whether
there's
any any noise effect from that pumping
station
[Music]
i think what we can do is we'll ask our
guests how much scope there is for
moving adjusting the position of the
pumping station
uh they tend to work on
uh
topography however it is a pumping
station so
if we could park that council of melon
we'll ask our guests
from an engineering point of view the
extent to which they could move that in
order to overcome your understandable
concerns
then let's see what we
get in discussion and then we can take
it from there that's
acceptable to you
okay thank you um another question uh
from the bundle um our
environmental officer p chisel on page
143 of the bundle
says a sustainability and energy
strategy must be provided um i wasn't
clear that that has been provided
and then i have a question about the
attenuation basins are they open or
fenced
energy is subject to a condition within
the
outline
application so that is a matter that
will be discharged separately but what i
have done is
explain to the committee just how far
keepmote are willing to go in order to
satisfy
the council's aspirations to tackle
climate change technically that isn't
part of the reserve matters but i
thought it was important to
share that with you this morning so that
would be dealt with
separately
sorry counselor your second point
oh yeah
at the moment there is no intention to
put a uh postal rail fence around them
but what we have secured
you'll recall from previous
presentations that
here suffolk council
county council like to see a one in four
gradient on the margins which is
actually better than the rospa
requirement at one in three so what we
have is a series of shelves where we
have a gentle slope at one in four then
a level plateau and then the slope again
at one in four and that enables people
to get out of the pond should they have
to fall in it easily
so
the question is i suspect we could have
a post-rail fence around it but to what
extent will that keep people out
and to what extent do we actually want
some sort of
chestnut paling fence around it because
most of the time it'll be dry and it
actually supplements these play
and facilities and informal recreation
on the estate but it would be possible
to have a poster rail fence around it if
members thought that was appropriate but
bear in mind that we achieve a much
higher safety standard in terms of the
profile than even rosper suggest
thank you for that that was another
question i had written down as well so
we're all thinking from the same thing
have you got any further questions at
this point i just have one question
myself
i noticed the layout of the
proposed site
what about the turning
safety for tankers
dustbin collection etcetera
the good news chair is that we have uh
obviously checked all the swept paths
and the the layout is designed to allow
all those movements safely
thank you thank you very much
yes please thank you
sorry i should have asked this earlier
but um
has there been any assessment of the
noise level that might be created by 65
heat pumps on the site given the
densities bugged excuse me
23 hectares
uh they're not silent uh pieces of
equipment or at least uh not not not in
my experience so has there been any
assessment made of the
likely noise level created by
heat pumps only
warming these dwellings thank you
it isn't an issue that has been raised
by our environmental health noise
colleagues and it has been clear from
the start that this scheme will include
100
uh air source heat pumps
thank you very much
um again another
interesting question i've had something
similar
through you jim i ask
may might it help discussion if my
colleague mandy was able to pull up the
the plan for
the site that councillor milan referred
to just so we can before you launch into
discussion we can actually
oh sorry i thought i've got voice like
yeah sorry i beg your pardon uh
councilman will read the parish council
statement thank you
thank you chair um i just received this
late last night and unfortunately
they're not able to be here but they've
asked me to to read it
um
they're kind of responding to um
vincent's responses so i'll try and sort
of make it flow
um
the parish council objects to the
geometric layout
and the officer seems to dismiss this
concern by stating that other aspects of
the scheme the open space and the
landscape are an improvement over the
original proposals relating to those
aspects
and by commenting on the scale and form
of the individual proposed units
first we would point out that there is a
flaw in this approach amelioration of
one aspect of a proposal does not simply
cancel out the undesirability of another
aspect
improvements in landscaping will be
welcome but that is this does not change
the geometric nature
of this iteration of the proposal
similarly the statement that this scale
and form of units is sympathetic to
those found in the immediate area may be
true but does not change the nature of
the layout which is
what the parish council's comments refer
to
and what and is what we feel has been
given insufficient consideration and
weight in the offices response
the proposed layout is incontrovertibly
geometric and this is not sympathetic to
either the adjacent existing development
or the vast majority of the rest of the
village
where even apparently straight roads
have arcs and kinks in them and which
sit at irregular angles to each other
a grid is an undoubtedly urban form of
layout and the parish council hopes very
much the committee will not grant
permission
for what constitutes an urban
urbanization of a rural village
then they go on to talk about the um the
concern about the footway
the parish council accepts that this
site is segregated from the rest of the
village and this is one of the reasons
that it has ongoing concerns
we're pleased that provision for
pedestrians was conditioned in the
outlying permission
but it is felt in order for the
condition to be meaningful cognizance
must be taken of the problems that
relate to realistic implementation at
this stage
even if the detail of the provision
itself is outside this stage of
determination otherwise there is a high
risk that the conditions the planning
authority has imposed will eventually
prove to be impracticable
impractical or unaffordable and so full
by the wayside along with trust in the
planning process itself the railway
bridge is already narrow and there is no
safe way to accommodate two-way
traffic
plus cyclists or pedestrians let alone
all at the same time the parish council
strongly recommends the need for proper
consideration of this problem is at
least referred to in any decision
arising from
the committee meeting today
and that ideally this is required to be
addressed before any above-ground work
is carried out
the parish council would ask whether
highways were aware in advance of the
grant of outline permission that
provision of the footpath under the
bridge would be made a condition
you've got ten seconds or five i'll stop
it there yeah so there's a lot of long
words in there but hopefully i yeah i
think they're covering old ground that
is not relevant to today and some of
that um but certainly an anxiety
understood
thank you for that um now if you'd like
to draw breath
um
you're ready to go again with your
statement oh no sorry kate i beg your
pardon kate holland i'm jumping ahead of
myself i've got all sorts of scribbles
here would you like to give us your
three minutes please thank you very much
good morning my name is kate holland of
invicta planning i'm here to speak on
behalf of the applicant keep moat homes
as members will be aware the site
benefits from an extent outline planning
permission with all matters reserved for
65 homes was granted in december 2020
this application is for reserve mata's
consent for the detailed landscaping and
layout of the site the design of the
dwellings and the site access
prior to the submission of the
application we undertook extensive
pre-application engagement with both the
district and county council including
planning housing highways and drainage
and there is as a result a number of
amendments were made to the application
including enhancements to the external
appearance of the dwellings this has
included the provision of architectural
detailing incorporating exposed rafter
feet flat top brick arches decorative
horizontal brick banding door canopies
and additional windows to the side
elevation
the development proposed proposals are
called with the parameters of the
outline planning permission maintaining
the approved housing mix site access
point and layout principles the
proposals include the provision of two
bungalows two one bedroom apartments
together with a mix of two and three
bedroom homes
the development as a whole provides a
mix of smaller dwellings
rather than some of the larger
properties indicated as part of the
outline consent in order to better meet
local needs all homes would comply with
the nationally described space standards
and building regulations part m42 this
would mean they'd be flexible and
adaptable for future residents
throughout their lifetime the inclusion
of smaller homes has allowed for the
open space areas to be increased in size
with ample room for the provision of the
play area and surface water drainage
features
a significant focus has been given to
the overall sustainability of the
proposals and an energy statement was
provided with the application
the development will be fully electric
with no gas provision the homes would
benefit from increased thermal
efficiency and be served by air source
heat pumps overall the dwellings would
achieve a reduction in co2 emissions of
40
and a reduction in energy demand of 60
the properties would provide a reduction
in water usage and those dwellings would
on plot parking would have access to
electric vehicle charging points
we'd like to take the opportunity to
thank officers for working with us to
develop these proposals and
to thank members for their time today in
the consideration of the points made in
this statement
thank you very much indeed you're well
in time
and i'm sure um our members will have
some questions for you i know councilor
mellon wants to pick up one earlier on
in a minute but councillor matheson you
wanted to ask a question thank you yes
can i
point you towards page 142 in the
paperwork which which is um our
sustainability officer peter chisnell's
um comments
um of september
i think they're the only
there wasn't a later one i don't think
um
and if you look sort of halfway down
that page if you up with us
um
yeah it seems it is disappointing that
the actual fabric specification of the
external walls etc etc um
is so we're not doing as much as we
could be doing
with the fabric um i wonder if you could
comment on that and then also the
following paragraph um which criticizes
the um
the permeability of air
um air tightness i think we usually call
it briefly um
and um you know whether you you couldn't
be doing something better than that
and second question really um
there's an awful lot of electric demand
built into this
um
which is fine
um but are we not going to produce any
electricity on the site
one way or another
i think on the fabric point in the
airplane ability they do i think they're
slightly in excess of building
regulations
um and i think from a commercial aspect
it was the air source heat pumps where
we focused
um these sort of additional spend on
sustainability aspects so we haven't got
i think you alluded to pv panels for
instance to
support the air source heat pumps as
well
thank you yeah well it's only questions
john rather yeah yeah well could you
could you
would you consider um offering them
um
offering them to to buyers
um you know buying off plan and so on as
a as a sort of additional items yeah i
mean
you know our constant point about this
is is that the once you've got a
discussion question we just don't need
to debate it's cheaper to do it then
rather than retrofitting yeah
you can listen to what's saying yeah and
and have you a response sorry yeah we
can all we can look at that as a as a
add-on for home purchases yeah of course
um councillor cast and then councillor
stringer thank you
thank you very much um
we're looking at quite a considerable
amount of hedge
being taken out of here it looks to be
seven meters thick in places
and about 60 meters long um
there is more hedge going in i might not
be right about that i'm doing that off
google earth the measuring tool can you
talk me through the um biodiversity net
gain on this site and how we're making
up for
that habitat and that harborage being
taken away
so we have submitted a a report which
shows the biodiversity enhancements on
the site um we haven't done the
biodiversity net gain assessment
um to support that yet but we do in
reference to the hedgerow i've been
looking at the aaa and it is a
sort of section of the hedge so some of
it will be retained where it can be
that's outside of the visibility display
coming south going north the visibility
displays mainly to the
right hand side or the east of the
existing hedgerow which is why most of
it can be returned
and then on the landscape master plan we
do
sort of supplement where we lose hedge
on the southern side by bringing it
inside of the visibility display and
re-establishing that hedgerow has been
since alluded to earlier for i think all
of that boundary going south and
additionally where there isn't hetero on
that southern portion between the bottom
edge of the site and the ditch we put a
hedgerow in for that whole extent where
there's currently no hedgerow
yeah just to clarify so you will
demonstrate a biodiversity net gain but
you haven't
not yet never completed that work yet no
yeah thank you
is that something we need to put in a
condition vince or not
it's a
a good point councillor kester we are
looking at uh discharging condition 10
which is biodiversity enhancement
strategy
my suggestion is if you agree the
recommendation that one of the things
that the chief planning officer will
need to do in connection with condition
10 is ensure that we have received that
additional information before he
discharges condition 10 and that way we
can be sure that
it hasn't slipped through the net
that sounds eminently satisfactory if i
can see heads nodding right
um thank you council castle the council
of stringer i think the next
caption
just want to uh point that two points
one is on the clarification about
heating
you suggested that putting in air source
heat pumps was an extra cost
that you were investing in the fabric of
this given that the nearest gas main is
three villages away
and the oil central heating
given the building regulations on
storage of oil would have meant you
couldn't have fitted this amount of
houses on the site
and if you had a
gas tank buried on the site somewhere
you would have also lost some houses
what were the other options that would
have been less costly that was the other
option the so we we have explored the
beneath ground gus and in the very early
days did have a proposal the same at
finningham road we the site we took to
committee a month ago we had a proposal
for gas beneath the ground which was
significantly cheaper than the air
source heat pump option but we chose to
pursue the air source heat pump option
the actual gas the amount of areas
needed for
the below ground gas storage is actually
less than i originally thought it would
need and could have been incorporated
into the proposals
one other thing
although
the chair has suggested that
how
this site will eventually connect to the
village is not for this meeting
however
sustainability is something that we're
looking at and encouraging the use of
sustainable modes of transport and to
get sight of that it is difficult if we
can't see the plan
does the section 278 plan exist has it
been submitted to the county council yes
and as far as i'm aware we've had a
first round of comments from the county
thank you
thank you council councillor war boys
thank you
thank you chair uh i think i flagged my
question up earlier um
it's really the only the provision for
the ongoing maintenance of the um
replacement planting the
water tenuration basins the swales the
ditches and so on which is quite
extensive
yeah so i'll cover all of the sort of
maintenance aspects
so the highways the public open space
and the surface water drainage will be
part of a management company
which will be provisions in place to
ensure that they are maintained in line
with an agreed
specification
the foul water pump station and the foul
water network um
will be
managed by an iwnl which are essentially
a independent water company that operate
exactly the same as angling moore to do
they're regulated by off-what
government by the same codes of practice
etc so the in summary the foul water
pump station and drainage will be
adopted the rest of the drainage
highways will be under management
company and
so how will this uh management company
be funded so residents pay
a annual charge for the management
company
which when you take out the aspect of
the foul water pump station which would
usually be quite a fb fee onto the
management company charge the highways
and drainage are pretty standard we do
on a lot of our developments
okay so the whole thing will be so
sustainable yes
thank you while you're on that subject
counselor mellon asked the question i
think it was you wasn't it about moving
the substation potentially wasn't it
um and i think i think somebody asked
about moving it because of
some issue of any standard attenuation
is there any likely to be any movement
with the topography of it um i've just
been looking at the the scope for moving
it i think the first thing to say is i
think on one of the plans there was a
brown
um suitably coloured circle around the
far water pump station which showed
these sort of
offsets that required i think it's about
12 meters and that shows that it goes to
the edge of the site boundary south
west um there's then a bit of a gap
between the dwellings to the east and
obviously you've got public open space
to the north um but in terms of being
able to
actually move that um it could be nudged
north a bit more so that it was further
away from the
houses to the south that you're saying
that got the consent
um that we discussed earlier that may
need a quite a bit of a reshape of the
attenuation basin but it could possibly
be nudged north
um when we go into debate we will have a
discussion as to whether that would be a
suitable um
arrangement and obviously through the
planning officer with your good selves
at some time
um so
councilor mellon did you have any
questions
boys was already on to it and i thought
we mustn't miss it
uh yeah i was just um trying to
understand how much noise there would
come from that pumping station
i i can't i don't know
what decibels the noise is all i know is
that the the sort of
regulated offset is that and that's to
cover noise smells etc um affecting any
any nearby residents
yeah i just wonder if we could have that
that plan of the the neighbouring
consent shown to us so that we can see
how close that house is yeah just before
we do can i just ask the legal officer
it isn't actually relevant well it is
relevant to the discussion we're having
but it is not this application we're
discussing it's an application outside
the site would it be appropriate for us
to show that to demonstrate
the distances that have been raised by
some of the members
[Laughter]
um i think it would be appropriate in
this case i mean it's it's um for
clarification purposes and it would aid
the discussion
thank you i just wanted legal
clarification on that so we now have
that available so if we can pop that up
please
not sure it actually does an awful lot
but is that what you alluded to whoever
brought that up was that you counselor
stringer yeah or cancel melon i'm not
sure who brought it up yeah if you look
to the far left of the red box
um that that property there which
obviously isn't under construction yet
is is right up against the
uh
the boundary of that plot and and the
plot we're considering today
um there's no there's no roadway in
between
there is on the middle plot in the
middle um
the one where the pointer is now
yes yes
[Music]
yeah this
is the
side wall of that property
so i understand the point you're making
about if the pumping stations in this
sort of position what might the impact
be but this is the
sidewall the entrance to that property
is there so
this is actually looking in this
direction you're quite right in terms of
this unit
has an access
from this point
but you recall the distance in here
between properties was 17
meters
this is actually
the properties here will when we go back
are further away so we are achieving the
minimum 20
that your standards require in terms of
building to building
separation
so
i'm grateful councilman you pointed that
out because it does enable us to look at
this
this plan but i am satisfied that
all the necessary standards that you
would normally apply
are met
thank you very much counselor casting
you have a question thank you very much
um so
we've heard the suds are going to be
maintained from uh for fees to
householders the um the roadways
it doesn't seem like the highways will
adopt those from the paperwork um could
you just talk about the maintenance of
those going forward
so they'll fall under the same
management company that manage the pos
and the drainage um so there'll be a
maintenance regimen of cleaning gully
pots etc repairing roads when they need
to be repaired and that will all come
under the the same management company
arena
which is which is quite standard for a
lot of our development sites
particularly the smaller nature
thank you very much any further
questions yes councillor matheson yeah
that the um
just i mean
the the
all the all the roadways and and the
suds and so on and so on that
maintenance
company um management company um so how
did how do the affordable houses fit
into that that scheme
um
you know in terms of their rent and so
on
so the um affordable housing provider
pays the management company charge um
the affordable housing provider that we
speak to upfront usually say we can only
pay up to say 220 pounds per month and
it won't exceed that and typically or
our management company charges they
won't they won't exceed the upper limit
of what they're willing to pay
so that's fought about upfront with the
affordable housing priorities that we
work with and they pay it the residents
don't in the instance of affordable rent
units thank you very much 220 pounds per
watt per a year the site per year in the
house that's just as an example
it was an example john so you know
i think it's interesting the points
being brought up because these sort of
things are happening all the time on
these estates aren't they anyway that's
for debate in a minute but um councillor
byrne yes a question please for that
just a
quick and small clarification point
again on air source heat pumps um
the system that they will connect to
will it be an underfloor heating system
and if so
will it be on both floors of the two
floor property
it won't be an under four heating system
it will just be uh panel radiators um
the underfloor heating system is usually
a lot more beneficial when you've got
much larger properties that require
better sort of space heating performance
than radiators can provide
and just one question i know
vince is going to ask a question for the
flats is there a good sound attenuation
between the two properties
yes there will be so there's a different
construction detail between the ground
floor mason and the first floor mason
that you typically get in a in a normal
house so yeah
thank you it's just that i know that um
if you have say stud walls upstairs you
can hear people hammering around all the
time so yeah it won't be like so it's a
typical construction detail which is a
lot more robust than any any standard
one you'd get in a
two-story dwelling
vince i believe has a question for the
applicant with your permission chair
thank you yes in the light of comments
made by um councillor mellon councillor
stringer and i know we've said that the
footpath issue is outside of the scope
of this but i think it'll be interesting
to hear
directly from you james
how you see the
system within condition 12 biting on
your development so the idea that you
have to get the
details approved and your section 270 in
place before you can commence presumably
you are aware of that how will that
impact your program and what what is
your ideal
program for getting this site moving
we're working on the section 27
agreement at the minute with the county
we're working with um
highways also i'm not too sure what the
detailed program is um but we won't be
for instance starting on plan to start
on site tomorrow because we've got
ecology works to finish off on the site
so we need to wait for march to hit the
weather to get warm and then commence on
site um later in the summer
so i don't know the the detail program i
don't know where we're at with county on
the highways 278
thank you very much indeed and now i
think of all the questions have been
asked if we can hear from councillor
mellon the ward member please thank you
yeah thank you chad um
so uh
there's quite a long history um of
applications to this site which i'll go
through briefly if i may um but
just start by um
welcoming the um the fact that there's
going to be air source heat pumps
throughout and that there will be
electric vehicle charging points
provided
um and i like the um the visual details
which the officers outlined it's good to
see those there um
i'm have to say i'm not particularly
keen on the layout the number of homes
on this site
means the site is tight
it is tucked in between the b113 and the
and and the railway and it is a dense uh
development
and as the parish council has pointed
out it is linear kind of boxy design
um
i think the officer even used the phrase
townscape it does look urban the gardens
are small and although there is some
open space
most of it is attenuation basis which i
have to say i'm not sure is terribly
useful space
um
so just to go back to
the the previous history on this site um
outline permission was granted in 2015 i
think it was 49 homes at that time um
but the site could not be sold and this
permission lapsed and then we had a new
application for 65 homes so increasing
the density of the sites
and that was approved outline
and and the committee met in
september 2019
um quite a long while ago but actually
the decision was not published until 14
months later
um so even though there was a tight 18
month limit for reserve matters to come
through
um
the the
they were given an extra time by by the
decision not being published for 14
months
and the most contentious point about
this site is the fact that the site is
distant from the services and facilities
in backton it is up the other end of the
village from the shop the pub the
doctors
so there's and there's also that
physical separation
from the bulk of the village as we saw
on the slides because of the main rail
line to norwich passing through the
village
and the only access from this
application site through to the main
part of the village is is via this low
narrow bridge under the railway
and currently there's no footwear under
the bridge
and so pedestrians have to literally
take their lives in their hands and
scoot through between the traffic so the
provision of a footway a protected
footwear is going to be a real benefit
from this site
there is a problem
at that bridge
in that the sight lines for drivers
approaching the bridge are problematic
the road is not straight but it's
slightly angled
and so you can't see through the bridge
until you're right
at it
so this this was a point of much
discussion back at committee a in 2019
and members were very concerned to have
a safe and suitable scheme drawn up to
be approved along with the reserve
matters i had a look at the committee
action sheet and it makes for
interesting reading because it
of the four things that are highlighted
it said that a condition for full
technical details of the proposed
footway scheme to be submitted
concurrent with reserve matters for
agreement and with the agreement of
suffolk county council but when the
outline permission was actually
published 14 months later this seems to
have been downgraded and that's the
condition 12 that we've dwelt on today
page 165 of your bundle
so this is the reason we don't have the
design
before us today for the footwear under
the bridge and i have to say i regret
that
if ever there was an application that
hinged on a single issue this one is it
without a safe route for pedestrians and
cyclists under the bridge the residents
of these houses will be completely
dependent on the car
so it's critical critical that the
design of the footwear and its
associated works is correct for the
particular circumstances of this bridge
and the configuration of the roads
approaching to it it's not something you
could do with an off the peg design
and what has been shown to us in
previous uh
designs
is a kind of give and go system where
the engineering and build outs would
cause drivers to pause before proceeding
but
i'm not convinced that this is the right
solution
we've had reference to the triple lock
but that still means we're dependent on
suffolk county council agreeing the
scheme and i would much have preferred
to seen it before us today
and i would really
encourage
members of the committee to defer this
application until we've seen the
detailed design
for the bridge thank you chad
um just before i have questions from
members can i just um concur
with the legal officer that the 106
agreement to which you really
alluded to at the end
is not
what we are debating today in the
matters before us
and just to point out that the section
278 is concurrently with suffolk county
council but we don't have the details i
do admit but can i just ask with legal
is that we are right in thinking that
sadly although that's one of the biggest
issues it's
what we are deciding today is what's on
the paperwork can i have legal advice
please
um yes chair that that is right um you
are looking at a reserve matters
application today so you're looking at
what's on the table in front of you i
appreciate these are all
bound up in that but the principle of
development has been accepted and that
was one of the principal issues so
whilst it is in your mind you are
actually looking at the reserve matters
and i think vincent did a good job of
explaining that at the beginning of this
presentation so we do have to
concentrate on the reserve matters we've
had some confirmation that 278 agreement
is being looked at but we haven't got
the details of that and the condition
does say
that prior to occupation it has to be
sorted out so the risk does lie with the
developer in that case that you know if
they are not going to comply with that
condition they can't
none of those properties can be occupied
and i think probably that's enough from
me
thank you can i just correct it i think
it was before they started vince could
you agree sorry yeah no i mean it's it's
all it's very involved and i understand
that's the joy of the triple look that
it means that
if this section 278 is not agreed
keep moat could not commence
so we will have the confidence of
knowing that there is
an approved
section 278 or not
and then at that point keep will have to
determine what happens
next
so um yes councillor mellon first and
then councillor mathison
sorry but i just needed clarity on what
we are looking at today that's fine
if it's some with the all permission
chair um could i ask the legal officer
just to confirm
um
because there's clearly been a change
between what was agreed
at the outline committee which was
recorded on the action sheet
that
that element was to come forward
concurrent with reserve matters and then
the condition 12 which is different so
that there's there's a kind of legal
space there which i actually want to
understand
but can i just clarify that we have been
told it is with suffolk county council
so that means it's running concurrently
but
as you quite rightly ask we need the
legal confirmation on it i understand
thank you um i do feel a little bit on
the spot here because as you did point
out there's a whole lot of history here
um i think from the action sheet is one
thing i'm not it would be a checking of
the resolution and the minutes to find
out exactly
how that translated into the minutes to
see whether what was issued at outline
stage
actually um you know
transposed that into the posit into the
permission and the conditions so i don't
think it's something that i can
give you any more information on here
without checking the resolution and
you know we are
it's one of those terrible phrases we
are where we are with it now it's some
time since the outline was granted
and um i think we need to um
to have a look at what's you know we
need to determine what's on the table in
front of us
right thank you council matheson did
have a question yeah well i yes i i had
this noted this precise question really
um
as to
whether whether or what point in the
past or the future uh any committee
would have actually looked at this um
proposal to to address the um
the um the bridge and um what is your
question my question yeah absolutely my
question absolutely is very clear one
and that is how did it come about
and this is more or less what councilman
is asking how did it come about that we
from having this said we wanted it
concurrent
with reserve matters it got changed
can you answer us as to where we are on
that point
i too would want to look back at the
minutes but i would also accept that the
section 278 is submitted concurrently
with the reserved matters
one came one comes to us and the other
goes to suffolk county council
okay
well that's for us to debate in a minute
counselor
uh wait a minute was there someone else
just
getting in a model was it counselor
stringer next or counselor melon had you
finished you got your counsellor
stringer please
yeah i i think we're just getting to the
nub of this now it's
it's really good that i can be here to
speak to you today
this is the first time
the fourth time this site has been in
front of the committee that at last
the person that is the elected county
councillor for this area is allowed to
speak about the actions of suffolk
county council here
because it's absolutely critical
in 1972 there was a protest under this
bridge i was part of it i was seven
years old
and we were demanding a footpath under
this bridge and we were told by the
county council quote there is no safe or
implementable scheme under that bridge
when i was then elected in 2009 to the
county council
i asked the question can we put a path
under this bridge i was told there's no
safe or implementable scheme okay
so we then see a planning application
that puts that footpath link in so we
ask can we see the scheme please is it
safe is it implementable
and all the way through that process
the county council's advice well the
path could be this wide it could be that
white it kept varying
we're not into debate yet councillor
we're into the questions still okay
sorry
but but but what you are raising is
something that i think if we can take a
five-minute break
for the legal officer to go and look
along with the planning officer to go
and look to see if they can assist us
and then when we go into debate please
you can be the next person to take the
degree
i think that would really assist you
yeah okay so can the planning officer
and the legal officer and
can you just go and see if you can find
and gemma can you all go and see
10 minutes we'll have 10 minutes to sort
of research this so
thank you very much
we have now legal guidance and the
relevant information so may i pass over
to christine to give us that guidance
thank you
thank you chair
we've checked the minutes of that
particular meeting and
as is the usual wording it was resolved
subject to the prior agreement of a 106
agreement
and conditions
on appropriate terms to the satisfaction
of the corporate manager
planning for growth to secure so i'll
just hand over to vincent and he can
explain um how that
was taken on from there
thank you christine the discussion
around the 106 took a lot longer than
anyone imagined because we had the onset
of
of covid and we were unable to
secure the 106
in a timely manner so by the end of that
process i produced a separate report to
the chief planning officer explaining
why there had been a delay
and that there had been active
discussion to try and secure the section
106
agreement
we set out all the terms and conditions
and the chief planning officer after
giving careful consideration to my
report to him exercised his delegated
authority in the way that is shown on
the decision notice
so what that means is that we are
discussing and debating only the matter
that's before us
um which was laid out by vincent right
at the beginning
so um councillor stringer you were um we
were um did we actually i do beg your
pardon i'm sort of losing it a bit
myself with all the comings and goings
had we gone into debate
not yet no we haven't so um i think
councillor
um any questions if you had a question
no right um so
um
counselor melon had spoken and we were
asking questions of counsellor mellon so
does anyone have any questions for
councillor mellon
no
right thank you for your input
so we now do
open up for
debate so
councillor stringer if you would like to
start that debate off thank you
thank you uh
notwithstanding the advice that we've
just had and i personally accept that
device
advice
there is a clear disconnect in here
between between the original decision
which is the third decision on this plot
of land
and today
and that is the express will
of that original committee that approved
the outline
to actually have sight
of how this site will connect with the
main part of the village and how it
could do that safely
that has been my concern all along sadly
this district cancels processes it
doesn't allow the county councillor to
appear at your
deliberations which frankly i've always
thought as is an anomaly that should be
closed up
in an instance like this
it is utterly critical that the decision
maker has had sight
of what they're about to approve
and to date
you haven't had that site
the bridge in backton is utterly
critical it is only 6.6 meters wide
it is the route for every pedestrian
every cyclist every car and every school
bus
to put in a two meter wide footpath
reduces the width of the opening of the
bridge so that a bus and a cyclist
cannot
safely go under the bridge
and it is that particular issue we all
along wanted addressed
for me
i totally see where the legal team is
coming from by saying this shouldn't
form part of your deliberation today but
you do have policies clear policies that
says you should encourage the use of
sustainable modes of transport including
cycling
you the committee we the committee are
the decision maker today
if i were going to vote today
given all of the
information i have to hand and all the
policies you have
knowing that the section 278 works have
been submitted
i would defer this
application so that you can have sight
of that so that you can with all good
conscience know the decision you make
today will increase the use in cycling
and not actually cause a safety hazard i
frankly would not trust this county
council officers to to implement all of
that for you i've been on site with them
they've talked about excavating the
railway banks to improve sight lines
none of this we've seen in a plan to
date
so before you make that decision i
certainly would
think hard about that if you do get
anywhere near a decision today
i would ask you to look at a condition
about the b1113 if this is going to be
constructed
you are on a
the b1113 is a designated lorry route
it has over four and a half thousand
vehicles a day that traverse it
most of the sites that are going in
backton at the moment there are five on
the go at the moment
have substantial amounts of parking
outside the site
if you were to allow parking along the
b1113 to build this site i think that
would be an oversight all of the parking
and deliveries need to be encompassed
within this site if we're not to bring
about huge chaos in this area that's all
i want to say thank you chair and just
to reiterate i will not be voting on
this because of my proximity to the site
thank you for that councillor
who else would like to speak please
counselor custom
um
yeah so i'd
i'd like to like go a bit further into
this um we do have a triple lock in
place
we need to um
that is protecting
um us from not getting this footwear
can you just
can you just clarify exactly how that
triple lock's going to work and um
so vincent
yeah yes please do vince please because
this is a really important part of this
i'd also
with your
permission to also tackle the point
raised by
councillor stringer in terms of
construction
traffic and associated paraphernalia
there is a requirement for a
construction method statement
part of that will be the location of the
compounds the location of on-site
parking for
contractors we will ensure that the
construction method statement adequately
deals with all those issues so there is
no temptation for anyone to try and park
on the the
triple one three
in terms of the triple luck
i know there's a danger we're going back
over stuff but
when you saw this previously our sister
committee saw this previously we had an
illustrative layout of the works
that had been seen
by suffolk county council as highway
authority and had been agreed in
principle so the actual planning
permission
refers to a drawing which shows the
works and then says despite that
additional detailed drawings are
required and that's where the 278 comes
in so the triple log is
that
there can be no commencement on site so
they can keep if you approve the reserve
matters cannot commence the development
so they can't put foundations in i'll
start putting the drainage runs in they
cannot start on site until
the 278 has been submitted but we know
that's been submitted and approved
so let's let's suppose
we end up in a position where suffolk
county council has approved the section
278 keep moat
can commence
now the point that christine was making
earlier is
they cannot then occupy any of those
units until all of those works
are in place
and that's how the sys how the lock
works you can't start until we know that
you've got a
scheme that will pass
safety order and is part of the 278.
once we know that's secure you can start
but then you can't occupy until we know
that those works have been completed
because as councillor stringer said we
don't want
new dwellings existing without that
important connection being in place and
that's how the system works so let's
think of another scenario let's suppose
278 is not approved
and let's suppose keep vote then start
that then is a
a matter for the council
as to whether it's expedient to take
enforcement action
and without wishing to pre-judge that my
thought would be
if it was essential to have that
footpath connection in place before
commencement and keep moab to start then
that suggests that we would be in a
position to take action against them
and that's the point about the risk is
with the developer but we have the
comfort of knowing
that we have that mechanism that will
stop them should they proceed without
that being in place
cancer casting you have some more yeah i
just wanted to carry on from that i feel
quite reassured by that it seems like
that's quite a robust way
of dealing with this
the no commencement on site is quite an
important part for me
it does um it does come down to
enforcement i trust the council would
act
should this not happen so
also this been
debatably in or
outside this application i do think that
we are
sort of working on something that's
already been
dealt with
and we don't need we this is not
something for this committee so um
the um
aside from that i think um
yeah i would like to see the um
biodiversity um net gain and i think
that's um
that that's a really important um
document for me the maintenance
to this site it seems to be quite a
burden
but
it all does what it's supposed to do and
it deals with all the issues
everything's
everything's covered and um there's not
when highways don't want to adopt roads
and angular water don't want to adopt
suds there's not really a lot of choice
but um the um the layout and the style
of this um yeah i think i think it's an
acceptable
application the um
i like the electric um charging points
for the vehicles i like the
air source heat pumps i think that's a
really important
addition to this
i had
concerns about the railway line
and the proximity to of some of the
houses to the railway line
um
the
environmental health looked into that i
know there's a certain standard i don't
know what it is now that we've
left the eu but it used to be a european
standard of noise level within a house
and the houses need to pass
i i think that's
all been dealt with in if environmental
health have come back and said this is
something we can achieve with this site
so um
i don't i don't really see any more
issues um
with this application
but i'll um
i'll hear from other councillors
thank you very much um we have cancer
stringer next councillor
muller and then councillor warboys i
think it was in that order i apologize
if we've gotten the model and then back
to you councillor matherson so cancer
thank you
i'll just be very clear about
the policy direction and focus on policy
which is what we're
here to do
the district council has clear policies
about encouraging the use of sustainable
modes of transport
you're comfortable with
the triple lock
i understand that
but the problem that the original
committee that approved it spotted was
the county council will only look at the
section 278 from a safety perspective as
to whether any impacts would be quote
severe
that's why that original committee
wanted this committee to see the drawing
of what goes on under the bridge
to see that what was being triple locked
would actually be policy compliant
and that is what you can't see because
you can't see the plan
that's the point you cannot judge
whether the width of the footpath
proposed will encourage or actually make
cycling dangerous
that's the point
and you can't address it because you
can't see it
it exists but we're not allowed to see
it
that's why the original committee said
it should be here today and it's not
which is why
i did suggest that if i was voting i
would defer it already exists we could
see it at another meeting and we could
agree it policy complies with us rather
than allowing a county council to offer
it look at it from one perspective only
thank you
thank you councillor councillor who was
next i've forgotten now councillor
muller thank you uh thank you chair yeah
i i um
appreciate the comments made by uh
colleague counter stringer and also the
comments made by uh councillor caston uh
but i think you know we've we've been
informed there is a triple lock
and the the particular issue here is not
part of the reserve matters application
we've been told that right the way
through
and there are a lot of good things going
with this particular application as
councillor casten has already pointed
out
one other point i would like to raise it
was mentioned earlier about the
possibility of the pumping station being
moved uh slightly but it was rather
close to one of the profits yet to be
built not on that this particular
application but
that that's the point i would like to
raise but it still comes down to this
issue we have got this triple lock we
know
from what we have been told that no work
can commence until that's actually in
place
and it was not in place enforcement
action could could take place and we
would expect that to take place so
that's the way i'm thinking at the
moment here on that thank you
thank you for that council award boys
thank you chair um
two two quite separate things really i'd
like to
say i just
firstly i'd like to put forward my
suggestion that the um
the development rights of the gardens on
the southern
um border
are restricted or prescribed or perhaps
even taken away and perhaps you could
consider also because of the
urban nature of the development that
development rights on all the gardens
are looked at very carefully because
there is a limited amount of
green space um
the development the developer has sort
of
extended and there's lots of positive
things about it but it could easily be
undermined if everybody was putting in
garden offices and
whatever in their gardens um you soon
see that biodiversity
diminished
the second thing is um i came this
morning i was thinking quite inside the
red box and about the red line about the
development um
but driving past the development and
then
being reminded that
this is a couple of weeks ago we were
talking about the development along
turnkey
oh no no it's not turnkey turkey house
lame
um
where there's
huge concerns there about the
development traffic along that road
uh that's the main lorry route into
backton
but we've got two situations here where
the
major concerns about
axis roads
uh that it's both of them if you like
not just the one
and
though i'm not naturally in favor of
deferment i do think of it as kicking
the can down the road to some extent in
this case
i find it very difficult to come to a
very favorable
position
unless i actually saw those
infrastructure considerations
actually resolved i i think there is a
i think if
if we do have the triple lock and if
development takes place and then there's
got to be enforcement i think it would
save an awful lot of trouble further
down the road if we defer this decision
until suffolk county council actually up
produced an infrastructure plan
that would
allay those fears
thank you for your comments um
counselor matheson you were next i think
thank you yeah i think councillor
stringer has has put them the main point
with great clarity
um
i mean i am sure that the the original
committee said concurrent and in fact i
i noted last night
a general observation i wanted to make
that that
it's not
it's not comfortable to sit in committee
making decisions with so many things um
left left to afterwards so to speak in
the conditions um despite the fact that
in many of the conditions were actually
set out in the outline stage
and and so i think we are moving towards
more frequently
saying condition will be concurrent with
rather than later stages
which is to be encouraged now i think
it's very clear in this case that the um
you know this is the count of the county
council response
is
on the policy
of sustainable transport is yet to be
is yet to come forward to us now
when we're usually making a decision
we've got their view
and then we make a decision
usually we say yep
they think it's okay and right we think
it's okay occasionally we say no we
don't agree with you now if we
decide now then we are we are taking
away that that option
and and what i'm wondering really is
because i mean yeah yeah
it's quite a good application
until you get to this problem
um and you know i wouldn't have a
problem in voting for it and what i'm
wondering is whether we can
approve it subject to
elected members and actually that's the
point elected members actually seeing
and agreeing
that condition that outline condition
so that's a question for the officers
and the legal to to answer whether we
can do it in that way
rather than go through it all again
in a couple of months time
unfortunately john what you're asking is
for us to have an informal committee
meeting to have a look at the papers
that the officers get
so you want to defer the whole thing
because you can't do a well we'll do it
with a tacit agreement it's either we
make an agreement or a disagreement we
can't do a tacit
so
no so you either want to defer it or
vote for it or vote against it so you
know that's your choice that'll be your
choice
well we haven't got there yet
well we haven't finished debating yet
but if you're proposing a deferral we'll
take that forward
do we have a seconder for deferral but
there are other people that want to
speak do we have a second of the
deferral please
no so i'm afraid john will vote
accordingly on how you'd feel
counselor burn did want
i
i have a degree of sympathy with the
concerns um
surrounding the legality well not the
legality but the
um the the implications of the legal
position i mean i i
i have to presume and i believe it's the
case that the approval of the section
178 would be
entirely the responsibility of the
county council
and whilst we should certainly
respect the position
of our
county highways advisors
we do have the right to apply our own
judgment to it that's always been the
case within our
planning meetings
but in this case it does seem that our
right to apply our judgment to the
county position
has been
removed from us if if that's not the
case i'd like somebody to explain
why because the decision is going to be
taken
um
and if it's a positive decision
regardless of whether we feel it's
adequately or sufficiently safe or not
or sufficiently convenient for the users
of that
of that route through to the facilities
of the village
then
we are
unable to exercise that judgment in this
particular case now if that's wrong
please explain
why it's not not not the case but
i don't think that that is a very
satisfactory situation and i have to say
but i'll listen to sit to hear what any
any other
any other members say in response to it
thank you thank you for that david
councillor but i mean i think we need
the legal and the planning officer to
explain to us what we're actually voting
on today although that is a great aspect
and i haven't spoken on the issue yet so
could legal and the planning officer
tell us you're saying we've been denied
it
um it was never am i correcting your
reading earlier that we weren't denied
it it was delegated and
so can somebody help us there please so
that david gets the right aspect of it
can i can i just explain before before
we get the answer to that we would
normally have this
information in front of us at this time
we would normally
be making this decision with that
information known
and therefore
we have um
we would be satisfied that we had all
the all the necessary information and we
could refuse
if we wish to refuse even though the
recommendation or the advice from
highways that there was
it was safe there was a safe safe access
through this through underneath the
bridge etc etc
but we can't do that in this particular
case
we if if we if we say okay we will we
will approve it with the triple lock in
place so so okay but
if
when we see what the uh
what the answer to the access under the
bridge is going to be
we think oh had we seen that at the time
we made our decision
we probably would have made it
differently that's what i'm saying but
that decision has already been made with
the no no the reserve matters the result
oh reserve matters doesn't include this
that's the point and and please will the
officers jump in and help me here
because i i listen i haven't spoken yet
and i would like to speak but i want
everybody to get their say first i
always do
what we are discussing is
in front of us and the consequence of a
reserve matters decision at this stage
which i'm i'm absolutely
aware we are able to take
is not in any way dependent on what we
are usually
what is usually available to us in such
a critical situation as this one
which is the access to the rest of the
to the accessibility of the site
pedestrian and cycle to the rest of the
village
i'll listen to what said and i may
change my view on that well i can only
ask ask the officer to explain my
understanding of what it's been
explained to me i'm not disputing what
you're saying it's just your
understanding needs to be
my response
would be councillor burn it isn't as
uncommon as perhaps you
think because every time well in my
experience over 42 years
where you are securing highway
improvements within the highway which is
what we're doing here
on a major site whether it's in a
section 106 agreement or within a
grampian condition such as condition 12
you don't always have the full detail in
front of you what we had
at the time of the outline was
an
illustrative layout that worked out the
principles of how those improvements
would be delivered
that was sufficient to put your minds at
rest or your sister committee at rest
that there was a workable solution
the actual mechanics of the engineering
drawings is a matter for the highway
authority and that's effectively what
we're saying to you is this morning you
are simply looking at the
access into the site you're looking at
the appearance of the properties you're
looking at landscaping the layout and
the scale
we are suggesting that each of those
reserved matters is acceptable
you have the security of having the
triple lock in place that would mean the
development couldn't proceed if we ever
got to a position where a section 278
agreement could not be issued
it's very common to have that
arrangement and i referred earlier to a
site in stowe upland where we first
developed the triple lock that is
exactly what happened there we had some
illustrative examples of a crossing and
all sorts of improvements the committee
was satisfied that that was a matter for
the county council's highway authority
to resolve but you had your minds put at
rest that
if they couldn't be resolved
the triple lock would prevent
development and that's what we have
have here
it's it's a common
approach
the works are in the highway that is a
matter for the county council as highway
authority but it seems to me and i know
it's a point raised by
councillors stringer and councillor
mellon this is not an issue i suggest
chair for the planning committee this is
a matter for
officers to pursue with the county
council as to why they cannot get access
to those section 278 drawings that's not
a matter for us
it might be a matter for those of you
who are also county councillors to
pursue that with the county
county council but as officers we are
satisfied that the scheme in terms of
the reserve matters is satisfactory
and we're at that we're at that point
but there's something else just for you
that also has crossed my mind
as you've heard this morning there's a
lot of development in backton there will
be a lot of sites being
built whether or not you approve this
one we've already got a lot going on
some of the developers have
freely entered into a dialogue with the
parish council some are more reticent
my understanding is that
keep moat have
given commitments to do that if they
haven't what you might want to do
in considering the reserve matters is
urge keep moat to open a new dialogue
with the parish council so that they can
be sharing this information
as they move towards assuming you
approve the reserve matters move towards
commencement
if keatmote wished to share those
drawings with
any member of this committee in the
parish council there ought to be a
mechanism through regular liaison and
you've used that successfully in other
villages
but it would need a
a commitment from from james to freely
enter into a stronger dialogue with ward
members and the parish council as this
development proceeds
can we just hold on a minute councillor
stringer i mean we'll we'll come to your
views um again in a minute but before
council burn comes back i believe the
legal officer wants to make comment or
gemma
so um you know it's all raising points
that we all need to hear so can we hear
them
um so there's a few parts there that i
would suggest
um
firstly condition 12 is not something
that's actually in front of us today i
appreciate that members were thinking
something concurrent with and that's not
the wording of the condition we've got
but it would still come in as a
condition and we would still have to
agree that so there is some mechanism
there
however i'd also suggest there's a
degree of caution there even if there's
something we don't like
that would still be for highways
highways have still got to agree this
through a 278 agreement they have got to
be content that is workable
there's
very difficult maneuvering there between
what planning would like and what is
achievable and safety safe in the
highway so i would suggest that that is
the mechanism and would be an
appropriate way of dealing with it and i
think that's where we've got to with
officers
is
we've got a position that controls it
it's looked at from a point of safety it
would come out of the water in that way
we've also got condition 12 that would
come in to us for that review
and at this point that what we need to
look at is those strict parts of reserve
matters so i would say that they are
separate from what we're looking at
today
i think it's
it is in the papers but i have to admit
i can't remember which page it's on uh
140 something i think
bear with me just a second
thank you
so on page 165 we've got the full
wording of condition 12. um just while
we've sort of flipped pages to look at
that i did want to pick up for council
or boys we've got both the construction
management plan condition and the
removal of pd rights condition already
on the outline
so they are there
but if we get revert to condition 12
that's at the bottom of page 165.
so the details have got to be submitted
to the local planning authority
uh obviously agreement with the highways
authority prior to commencement of any
works details agreed to be delivered in
accordance with a timetable so we'll
have a timetable for that improvement
and no dwelling should be occupied until
the improvements have been completed so
that again just to run through that does
that help chair
now to counselor burn um you want it to
come back and uh you may have some other
issues so please continue no other
issues just on that particular one so
i'm just uh
reading on 165 the only opportunity if
you like of influencing
the outcome
of
county highways deliberations on on this
will be
um
the local planning authority
uh
in consultation with local highway
authority
prior to
uh commencement of any works
and
so yes indeed it that would that would
presumably be an officer connection
rather than a member connection
so there's no member opportunity for
influencing this at all
i might just query that with committee
services it will just take just a second
quickly
we're just considering whether there was
an opportunity to bring the discharge of
condition in front of committee i don't
think we've got any
prior uh
experience of that between us to do so
um so it's not something i could say
here in this room here and now we could
definitely do but certainly we could
take that away and look at whether there
was an opportunity to do that if that's
what members were minded to and
certainly i'm sure vince as the officer
is sat in the room here he's hearing
this and he would speak with the ward
councillor at the time so i appreciate
that doesn't necessarily give you
certainty but there are two options
there one of which is a certainty that
we could do in terms of that discussion
with the ward councillor at the very
least and if members were minded on the
committee option i can certainly explore
that
so
could we put it as a condition
that
no i can say
i'm just trying to i mean unfortunately
that is not what we are
i keep coming back to the what we are
discussing and i i haven't spoken yet
and i will speak um when when
everybody's finished speaking
so no we couldn't put a condition on it
okay right council does anyone does any
of our advisors wish to make any further
comment
before i come back to councillor burn to
let him finish his comments
no
no councillor bern if you'd like to
continue please thank you
say that um
what gemma has just just told us is
to a small degree reassuring
but
um
if if that is a possibility i'd rather
see it
confirmed
in advance of making the decision
than uh confirmed after the event that
it wasn't possible um and so
on that basis
uh
a deferral would seem to be say i hate
to say this because i don't like
deferrals as such they need you know we
shouldn't we shouldn't be doing that but
if if unless it's avoidable um
unavoidable in this case um it probably
is avoidable unavoidable sorry avoidable
but um i don't feel as comfortable as i
might be that's all thank you
vince just wanted to pass another
comment it seems to me that
we might not need a deferral subject to
gemma confirming but
all discharge of condition applications
are made to the local planning authority
and virtually all of them are dealt with
by officers
but it if it is the will of this
committee that when it comes to
condition 12
you make an exception
and we are required to bring it to you
despite the scheme of delegation
that would seem to be
the way forward
and now i'm confused so are we going to
vote on what we've got before us i would
i would argue that you're perfectly able
to
vote on the reserved matters but what we
are saying is in doing so
you will instruct officers
to bring the condition 12 discharge
and only conditions to committing as and
when those details are formally
submitted and i have just had
confirmation from chief valley officer
that that is something we have done in
the past so we could therefore do it
that sounds comfortable
right
so
david you've had a more comforting
comfort comfort now haven't you
you're more comfortable with that now
right
so um does anyone else counselor casting
yes and then council matters and then
i'll have a good
i would like to avoid deferral on this i
don't think that that's what this
committee's
um meant to do and also
i don't feel like this is something we
can ever do anything about so deferring
is not really an option for me i do
i think it's sensible for
this to come back as a very small
condition
that we can look at and we can see that
it works and
we we are getting what we um
what we expect i do
have faith in highways to deliver
something and safety would be my
if if that's what they they use to make
the decision that would be my first
thought it's got to be unsafe
and it's um and if it's delivered it's
the it's the end of the
problem for me i do um
remember
in summersham 42 houses and um planning
a
saying that we want a footpath an
accessible footpath
in the section 106 and
that never happened
so it does concern me it is really
important to make sure these things
happen
um
so
i think i've i don't want to defer but
if there is a condition if we can
do this and
bring back just this matter
to this meeting if that's what this
reserve matters is for if that works i
think that would be that would be good
and that would reassure a lot of people
on this committee and deal with a a
blockage that we seem to be in at the
moment
right okay well so is that a proposal or
is that um
you know
with that in place is it yeah well i'd
like to um i'd like to hear
exactly what that would um look like
in there and i'd i'd like to um maybe if
if i'm proposing i'd like to
add some conditions of my own and just
see the committee feels about that
yeah yeah absolutely i've been just i've
been aware of various points in the
debate so if i pick some of those up i
think you've been mentioned so at the
moment i'm looking at an approval as the
recommendation on page 121
that we delegate to the chief planning
officer to confirm biodiversity net gain
under condition 10 prior to discharge
and to review the location of the
substation with condition 12 to return
to the development control committee so
it's not a condition it's an on our
action sheet and i would take that away
report that back to chief planning
officer and we'd set something up on the
um
original reference to our system that
would essentially and would it come back
to planning b or play can you put dcb if
you have appropriate that we've
that we all understand what's going on
yeah i've added the b to the end so we
can make sure that that's 12 control b
specifically absolutely
thank you
right so with that in mind
yeah and
the other two conditions that i would
i've got written down here have just
been
said um the biodiversity and the um
and an assessment of the um whether it's
acceptable for that pumping station to
be
where it is with the new planning
application being
considered um and also um
where possible i'd like to see permeable
driveways and surfaces
um
i don't i haven't seen that in in here
but um
i'd like correctly if i'm wrong but
shouldn't all surfaces be permeable for
well the good news is we can pick that
up
under a separate condition that isn't
part of the reserve matters so we can
deal with that
okay thank you yeah i'm i'm happy thank
you
councillor muller
thank you chair i'm more than happy to
second uh case for catherine's
approval with the conditions that he's
actually just discussed thank you
boys you had your hand up and i haven't
spoken yet so if you would like to
put your points across and speak to the
motion thank you thank you chair yes uh
just just um clarify in my own mind
that
if these if this is a planet application
is approved with the
conditional of the discharge of
condition 12 is accepted
um at what point will building commence
will building commence as soon as this
is approved or with the discharges no no
the grampian condition says they cannot
commence until
this
problem section
12 278 is approved and agreed so they
can't start until that happens thank you
yeah um
yeah just just to say that i'm very
pleased that the officers have now come
forward with the way of of um not
revisiting the whole job um thank you
very much right
burn did you want to come back i didn't
i don't know whether your hand was up or
not
right okay um
so while you're writing everything down
and giving it all clear
i too have been listening to this for
many years
and i too know the area that's concerned
um i'm only going to briefly comment
on that footpath and the issue with
suffolk county council
i'm pleased that we may have found a
route through to assist everybody
to let them understand
that it's not something that we're
flippantly dismissing or not
so i absolutely understand where
councillor stringer and councillor
mellon who live in the area and are the
ward member are coming from
so i'll move on to what we have before
us
and i think
um
i tend to disagree with the parish
council on the um the layout of it
it suits somebody and it suits others
not
but i think with the design of the
properties that we've got coming forward
i think they're rather interesting
and i liked the brick wall i liked the
bay windows
and i liked a lot of the um
the general layout of everything there's
no triple parking and i think um vince
summed it up at the beginning that it's
100 ndds
um it's part four m42 of the building
regs 100 air source heat pumps and i
heard councillor burns query about the
noise of them and i must admit
um i i too worry about them but it's the
way forward it's where we're going
and the electric vehicle charging points
um and i think you mentioned vince that
this could be used as a benchmark
and i think it is refreshing to have a
new applicant in our area prepared to
engage with our community and i can see
councillor stringer frowning
[Laughter]
well i've never come across the thing um
but i was a bit concerned about
councillor stringer's comment um and
councillor stringer i quoted you
verbatim
um and it did worry me a little bit
where you said you didn't trust suffolk
county council and i find that rather
rather alarming that you should say that
in full council because we have to trust
what's coming forward but we now have
the opportunity to see
whether your trust is
with them and being a county councillor
i'm sure you will make sure they are
with us
so i hope very much that the uh
the matters are all resolved so i have a
proposal and a second i think do we need
the conditions read out again or are we
happy with what we've gone over
right so may we go to the vote please
thank you chair um i'm happy gemma do
you just want to read the conditions out
just so we're 100 sure on
yeah so we're looking at approving as
the recommendation on page 121 and then
we're going to delegate to the chief
planning officer to confirm biodiversity
net gain under condition 10 prior to
discharge and to review the location of
the pumping station position
and then not as a condition but as an
informative to myself to the chief
county officer that condition 12 will
return to development control committee
b
essentially as an exception not
something we would normally do but to
allow that resolution in this case
that would be my proposal at the moment
thank you chair
thank you chair
the vote is now open in modern.gov
counselor casting is your
app not working no i i can't seem to
vote could i vote verbally
of course thank you i'm for my own
proposal
okay thank you chad that is six votes
that is
none received yet